okay
okay so I'm going to talk about today
today talk about transparent starts from
dark compilers and this is joint work
with Japan yak and then fish who I
borrowed a lot of the slides from so
what is the summary of the results today
so we already heard a lot in this week
about polynomial commitments so this is
also going to be about polynomial
commitments and especially it's going to
be a new polynomial commitment scheme
with a transparent set up so no trusted
set up which has lock size evaluation
proofs and block size verification and
this gives us through for example
through Libra or a lot of the other
talks we saw this week this directly
gives us transparent setups nark for
arithmetic circuits with logarithmic
proof size and logarithmic verification
time and using the vh amir transform on
a multi round public point argument so
yeah i'll ask before what is a
polynomial commitment scheme well so
polynomial commitment scheme is a
commitment to a polynomial of degree D
and the commitment is ideally short and
then it enables these small proofs that
evaluate the polynomial over some finite
field on a point Z and also prove that
the degree of the polynomial is bounded
so often these these protocols prove
both so a little bit more formally we
have a set up algorithm which generates
the public parameter a commitment and
opening just like an ax normal
commitment but then we also have this
evaluation protocol which might be
interactive where the prover can claim
that there exists a polynomial which is
in the commitment and that the
polynomial ectly evaluated at a point is
equal to some other value and ideally as
I said the we want the commitment to be
small and we want the communication to
be suppl in ere indeed for univariate
polynomial or if we're talking about a
multivariate polynomial then we want the
communication to be sub linear and the
total number of coefficients in the
polynomial
and the security properties that we want
are just a standard
commitment binding property I won't talk
about hiding our knowledge in this talk
but you can also achieve that and for
the evaluation protocol it is there's
two different notions one is a sort of a
binding property that I cannot evaluate
the same polynomial at the the same
commitment at the same point to two
different values the other one is a
knowledge polling property which we will
achieve where I can prove to you every
time I evaluate the polynomial on any
point it is actually possible to extract
the underlying polynomial and we will
achieve this this argument of knowledge
property and ideally what we would want
is a transparent set up where the setup
has no secrets and this is publicly
verifiable so trust the set up
transparent set up there's multiple
words right now
and previous constructions for for
polynomial commitment other than the one
that we saw before used by linear maps
and they especially they use this
trusted set up where you have a CRS
which commits to all of the monomials of
a secret evaluation point so there's the
secret point S which the Serb chooses
and then the CRS is just the monomial of
this polynomial up to some degree T and
in this work we achieve this polynomial
commitment scheme with transparent set
up constant size communication
commitment and only logarithmic
communication and evaluation and
verification time Amiga and why do we do
this well mostly to make Riyadh happy
it's a gift because it was on his wish
list but also as we've heard a lot this
week because we can build snarks from it
so just to very quickly recap what is a
snark
well it is a proof where the prover
proves that he knows the witness to
simulation or so to say we often talk
about circuits so in those inputs
through the circuits that computes the
relation that say it's true and we want
the succinctness property that the proof
is very short we're somewhat efficiency
in that the verification time should
also be short ideally for
and we want an extraction property
saying that there exists an extractor
which can extract the witness from
approver that succeeds on with with
non-negligible probability so and
ideally we want the snark without it
with the transparent setup where there's
no secrets in this setup so everybody
can publicly verify that the setup was
done correctly so unlike in these gGPO
based Snorks where you have to trust
that the setup was done correctly for
example z cache and sometimes they even
go wrong as in z cache but here if we
don't have this trusted setup then
everybody can just run an algorithm to
check that the setup was done correctly
and the idea to achieve this is is sort
of to follow you vaults framework for
using an information theoretic thing
namely a polynomial IRP which I'll
define in a second and turn that into an
efficient interactive proof using a
polynomial commitment and then if
there's a public coin protocol then we
can use the fiat samir transform to
again compile this another cryptographic
compilation step to turn this into a non
interactive proof snark this is a yes an
argument yeah I mean I guess if you have
a yeah I guess it would be hard to
achieve succinctness without an argument
here yes okay well yeah I guess it
depends on the properties of the
polynomial commitment scheme no I guess
if you want 16 to the description okay
so this would be a doubly and efficient
interactive fragment and we already saw
this this comparison before and the one
thing that I want to focus on is that
there's no previously there was no snark
that has work that has logarithmic
purely logarithmic proof size and
verification time and doesn't have other
than snarks
but they have the trusted setup so this
is the first snark that achieves its a
first practical scenario Kevin rather
than than CS proofs which use very heavy
PCP and that achieves logarithmic proof
size and logarithmic verification time
and again the recipe that we'll use is
from your vaults talk that will have
some and this is in general the recipe
for creating these proof system is to
have some information theoretic proof
system and then compile it and one
information theoretic proof system is a
linear PCP and we already heard about
this and the idea of a linear PCP is
that I have some proof vector and then I
can the verifier can make Oracle queries
to this proof vector that return an
inner product between the query vector
and the proof and okay all showed that
you can using linear homomorphic
encryption you can create a form of
linear PCP into a snark so 1/16 proof
but with a linear verification time and
correct proving time and then as a
compiler using linear homomorphic
encryption and then the work by GG PR
showed that we can create P based linear
PCP using linear only encryption to
something that has constant verification
time and constant process and the way
that these QPS work or these are ones
yes pre-processing snarks work at a very
high level is that the queries are
pushed into this pre-processing step and
they're hidden by there's a hidden
random alpha chosen by the trusted
seller and in the compilation into a
linear interactive proof we use this
linear only encoding which forces the
prover to basically apply the right
query vectors so I push the query
vectors into the set up and then I
somehow need to force the prover to only
be able to do these linear queries so
not do any
karate queries or something else with
the proof and this is done using using a
heavy cryptographic tool called linear
only and coding and the problem is that
this approach appears to fundamentally
require sort of a trusted setup because
I really need to push these these these
these query vectors into the into the
set up and there's another another
information theoretic object that we
heard about this week our interactive
Orica proofs which are the the Oracle
proofs OPC piece where the verify just
checks this point queries so he just
checks random points and the interactive
ogre proofs are the multi round version
of this where in every round the prover
sent some Oracle to proof and then the
verifier can query this Oracle and the
nice thing about our piece is that we
can compile it very efficiently and it
has great efficiency gains of a
classical PCP and has very lightweight
compilation that for it only is a
symmetric key cryptography and we can
build you know we can build Starks and
Aurora and and even polynomial
commitment schemes from it but in
general they have sort of the the proof
size is still log N squared unless you
use very heavy cryptography again then
you can bring that down a little bit or
you can bring that down but it seems
sort of if you really want to gain the
benefits of it you have to deal with a
relatively large proof size I mean it's
still a poly logarithmic but you know
since we already have that we want to do
better so what about sort of combining
these things write a linear PCP is is
it's a single round thing and an IO P is
a multi round thing so what if we have a
linear ILP and this was recently
explored by by Henry and others and well
and it turns out that this actually
gives you something some new interesting
properties
we can even extend there we will use a
subclass of these linear IOPS which are
polynomial i apiece so what is the
polynomial IRP well the idea is that
every query is not some it's not generic
linear queries the query is just a
polynomial evaluation so clearly this is
a subclass of a linear IOP because I can
always express a polynomial evaluation
as an inner product as you thing just
said I can express it as an inner
product between the monomials of the the
evaluation point and the coefficients so
this is so what if we you know want to
do a little bit more what if we want to
do coordinate queries or in a product
between the coefficients and other
Oracle's and we actually show in our
paper that there is a generic reduction
between these information theoretic
objects so with the polynomial PCP it's
it's actually there's a you know as long
as I can do these queries then I can
also do point queries I can show you
that one of the coefficient this has
some value so this gives us kind of this
hierarchy that linear pcps are the most
powerful thing and the subset of them
are polynomial pcps which are more
general than point PCP sand and the IOPS
are just the multi round version of so
this is what you send in each round in
an IFP and then an IRP is a multi round
version of this information theoretic
object so now how do we compile that or
I guess first I'll show you some
polynomial I our piece for NP so we
heard about Sonic which is the
polynomial I appear it's a two-round
polynomial P for any NP relation that
makes one bivariate query and three
univariate queries two polynomial
overall the promise that bivariate
queries are the the bivariate query is
the bivariate polynomials quadratic in
the size of the circuit so they also
show a nice transform that you can
transform this to a five-round
polynomial P with 24 univariate Oracle
queries
of degree size of the circuit and for
uniform circuits so if you can vary the
bivariate polynomial is basically a
description of the circuit so for
uniform circuits if you can evaluate
this very efficiently then you can just
use the the two round version of the IRP
and the verifier can just evaluate the
circuit polynomial locally so this is a
very nice property of this protocol and
what we do is we apply the new
commitment to Sonic and we get a
trustless snark with with log and proof
size and log and verification time and
practically this is also fairly short
not as short as by linear snarks but
less than 10 kilobytes
so we support the polynomial commitment
scheme it's for multivariate polynomials
so I guess Sonic only uses in the end it
compiles it to something that only uses
univariate polynomial but our polynomial
commitment scheme supports both
univariate as well as multivariate
polynomials and actually this comes here
so in work Spartan close so these are
proof systems that are based on multi
prover proof systems and in Spartan you
can basically so reduce the satisfiable
of any circuit c2 to this this check
over a multivariate polynomial is
actually multi linear polynomial and you
have three witness pull it over one
witness polynomial of degree one and
then you have these polynomial
describing the circuit which at least
and Spartan have three Loxy variables
and we've also heard Libra which uses
sort of has the dependence and the depth
of the circuit but brings this down to
Loxy variables and it's this whole
family of gki based protocols which as
you Peng just showed so nicely in the
last talk can also use the polynomial
commitment scheme so they also fall into
this category of polynomial IOPS and I
guess the theorem in in this paper is
that they exist the polynomial I appeal
for any relationship which uses a 3 Loxy
variate multi linear polynomial and for
uniform circuits you can again evaluate
this polynomial locally so you only have
to do three queries to to these smaller
polynomials so let's talk about the main
construction so how do we do the step
one and our new polynomial commitment is
to encode the polynomial as an integer
so we have a polynomial of degree at
most D and I will only talk about the
univariate case there's also extends to
multivariate polynomials but you'll have
to trust me on that
so the idea
we want to encode this polynomial as an
integer and we do this very simply by
just evaluating the polynomial at a
point Q such a cure is larger than than
the size of any of the coefficients so
we first lift the polynomial to the
integers which is one important point
and and each of the coefficients is now
between zero and P and then we evaluated
at Point Q and to make this very
concrete say we have a polynomial 4x
cubed plus 2x and so on and we're over
z5 so then if Q is equal to 10 then the
evaluation of the polynomial is just the
sort of each digit is as a coefficient
in the polynomial so you can see right
here this is 4 2 1 3 and and in general
this is sort of the intuition for the
encoding and this also shows that the
the the size of the encoding is roughly
oh it's between I think Q to the D and Q
to the D plus 1 so it's as the encoding
is as long as the polynomial itself but
we've now encoded as an integer
q to the d well Q is greater good CP
will see in the second why we wanted
maybe to be greater than P it's an
objective map exactly it's an objective
map from polynomials with bounded
degrees to introduce yeah and Q to the
DS later than is larger than P to the D
and so the reason why we want Q to be a
larger than P is what actually first
let's state some fact so every integer
is uniquely decodable to an integer
polynomial with with small positive
coefficients and we can also decode it
this is the variant for for for if we
want their coefficients to be both
positive and negative and but the other
fact about this is so why do we want Q
to be larger well because the encoding
has nice homomorphic properties so if I
have F of Q plus G of Q this is equal to
F plus G of Q if Q is large enough so if
there's basically no overflow between
the coefficients so in this example say
F of 10 is equal to 4231 and G of 10 is
equal to 1/4 for 3 you can almost read
of the polynomial of this because I but
then we can see that F of 10 plus G of
10 is equal to 5 6 7 4 so this is 5 to
the X cubed and so on and so forth so
this is the encoding of this polynomial
so if Q is large then we have a data
form of morphisms so we need to in the
end in the protocol we need to choose
the Q large enough such that all the
homomorphisms we do on the polynomial
are supported without overflow such that
we can guarantee that all of the
homomorphisms
work see apparently not that easy even
yeah this should be it for someone's
reading the sites so we also have
actually a monomial homomorphism or
actually we can even do polynomial
products but we really only care about
the monomial
prism so I can compute X to the K times
f of X this just maps to Q to the K
times F of Q right so in this example
for this H of X then I have x squared
times H of X is this polynomial and we
can see that this also works in the
encoding space so the second the next
thing that we need is a group of unknown
order so this is some group and we will
generate this group and and the
generator and this is so you can see
that the CRS is constant size it's only
the description of the group and and and
a random element actually not a generate
the necessary of this in this group and
the property that we want from this
group is that the order is unknown so
that no one knows the the order of the
whole group and actually we require
stronger properties such as that no one
can compute the order of any single
element or multiple of the order so why
is this important well because if I
compute G to the X for an integer Z then
I cannot reduce Z this X mod the order
of the group so if I know the discrete
logarithm for prove or the assumption I
see at least in generic groups what it
states is that if I know the discrete
logarithm between G and C to be some
integer X then I cannot find another
integer discrete logarithm between okay
I cannot find another discrete logarithm
between these two elements otherwise I
could compute a multiple of the order of
that element and this group also
preserves the homomorphisms
of the integer encoding that we had
before so for example its was I additive
Li homomorphic so see I'm following so
the commitment over the integer works
and this is and now this is about making
the commitment smaller
right so this isn't just encoding of the
polynomial as an integer and but as we
said before this thing you know it
preserves all of the information of the
polynomial so it's at least P to the D
but now we want to have a short
cryptographic commitment to it and for
that we use groups of unknown order
which give us a constant size so it only
depends on the security parameter the
this map which Maps integers to group
elements that it preserves so how do we
commit well we lift our polynomial which
is in a field to the integers with small
coefficients so we really commit to not
polynomials in a field but we commit to
integer polynomials with boundary
coefficients we evaluate that at Q and
compute G to the F
yes so G to the integer encoded
polynomial so we have this you know I
said for a polynomial commitment we want
the property that the commitment is is
short and here we have that it's it's
constant
this is a I'm not going to talk about
hiding it all in this talk but you can
also achieve
so so some people in you know I guess
I'm using commit loosely I'm using
commit here also for just the binding
commitment not the the group operations
are the expensive I mean yeah addiction
practices these groups of unknown order
actually quite expensive but yeah
where we want to make life easy for the
verify so now I'm going to present the
the first argument of knowledge that the
proven knows the polynomial which it
committed to and that the polynomial is
of a most degree D and we call this a
guillotine argument of knowledge to get
a nice acronym dark out of it but also
because it works over the integers and
so the statement is that they exist the
polynomial actually it's a polynomial
and the integers with bounded
coefficient which has the bounded degree
and the commitment is equal to the G to
the encoding of the polynomial so well
if it's a constant polynomial then we
can just send it to the verifier again
this is not to your knowledge and the
verifier just checks that this is in
fact a constant so that he can decode it
to a constant and then checks that the
commitment was done properly and then we
want to build a recursive protocol I
think in the first workshop then gave
the general recipe for getting any lock
size protocol it's you do some recursion
you split it into halves and then you
combine it again so that's exactly what
we're going to do so this commitment is
done and now this is a proof of this is
something different this is just the
proof that it's basically a proof that I
committed to a degree D polynomial
actually argue it's well sorry it's an
argument of knowledge I will show you in
a second how to then turn this into an
evaluation proof the extractive works
through it's an interactive protocol so
the extractor just works through
rewinding so there will be some
challenges and and the extractor works
by rewinding and it can actually yeah it
can so yes so but this already this
protocol already has extract ability so
I can extract if the prove it does this
protocol once then I can extract the
underlying polynomial and but let's
let's see the protocol first so the idea
is I wanna again I want to split the
it's very actually quite a simple
protocol because the idea is just I
split the polynomial two halves and then
I somehow combine it and then work on
polynomials of half of the DB so what
are the two halves
well it's F L of X plus X to the over
two times F R so these are the the first
the the lower coefficients and these are
the higher coefficient and each of them
is degree t over to around the town'
omit the rounding down and then the
verifier can check later on using the
monomial homomorphism that f of X is in
fact the combination of these
polynomials and then the verifier just
sends a random challenge alpha and we'll
recurse on the linear combination of
these two polynomials so this is where
the additive homomorphism comes in and
so we need Q to be large enough to
support this but we can see that f prime
of X is of degree D over 2 so after log
T steps we'll get to the D equals 0 case
right yeah I mean any recursive protocol
looks um yeah so it's I'm sure I think
you know there the check here is
slightly different but you could also
use a sort of exactly no it you could
also here user user user like this FFT
base check you could split it into even
an odd coefficients and things would
also work out but let's see how we
compile this to to cryptographic
protocol
well it needs to support these two
homomorphisms officially right we need
the monomial homomorphism and we need we
need the monomial homo person and we
need the editor formalism so and I'll
show you where the monomial that yeah no
and it's certainly interesting if we can
you know use some other cryptographic
compiler to ensure that this works so
the so this is the basically the entire
information theoretic protocol and here
we have the cryptographic compilation of
it and now actually this is all so now
we can see how we do an evaluation well
it's exactly the same protocol but in
every round the prover also sends you so
I'm claiming that f of Z equals Y mod p
so basically in every round I will also
send you FL of Z and F rfz and then do
the same linear combinations and instead
of sending you the polynomials in the
clear I'll commit to them using the the
commitment that I described before
so the verifier just checks here again
here it uses the monomial the Minami
homomorphism to check that the
polynomials are consistent and then it
takes a random linear combination and
and recurs on it
in the recursion somehow you need the
bound and the coefficients so in the
final step I will check that the
polynomial is constant size and then in
the extraction basically so it's really
important is this bound check is really
really important because it tells me
that the final polynomial is in : even
on the constant polynomial and then in
every round I can extract just using two
different challenges alpha I'll talk
about that a little bit more in a second
but the the high-level idea is that then
you know I can Minh see that you know
the the in every round the degree of the
polynomial and the extraction it doubles
in the evaluation it has so that gives
me an exact bound on the overall size of
the polynomial oh yes also we also need
to make sure this is I'll come to this
again in a second but I say now this
check actually isn't in the final
protocol it's not going to be that F is
less than Q over 2 it's going to be that
F is kind of significantly smaller than
Q over 2 because then I this gives me an
in the extraction this gives me
basically an argument that the final
extracted polynomial also has small
degrees so that it is still uniquely
decodable right I always need to make
sure that the committed polynomials are
uniquely decodable so this is where sort
of all the magic about the encoding
happens because it's it's you know if I
I know that the only homomorphic
operations are I do are this so this
gives me a bound on how much the
coefficients change in each round
exactly the the the well it needs to be
a little bit larger than that because I
lose both in the in the evaluation and I
lose in the extraction and it's actually
an interesting question how to get
tighter so there's one issue with this
protocol which is that the verify needs
to do this check whether the
communication you can intuitively see
that it's it's pretty short right I send
you to group elements I send you to
evaluations so all of that is constant
we have lock D rounds so everything is
nice but here the verify needs to do
this consistency check and it needs to
compute CR to the Q to the D Prime and D
prime is actually huge it's a it's
linear in the degree D so this
exponentiation is takes time linear in D
so what can we do about that right this
is not verify efficient well thankfully
there was the the best paper you're
equipped the best write young researcher
paper you're equipped this year which
gave this beautiful proof of
exponentiation in the context of
verified wave functions which is a
protocol for showing that in a group of
unknown order that X to the Alpha is
equal to Y and the protocol is if alpha
is smooth then the protocol is well if
you if you account in group operations
it's Lachie it's constant and it's
constant proof size it's literally a
single group element and the
verification is also extremely efficient
and it relies on this adaptive food
assumption which is a falsifiable
assumption and sort of the dual of the
strong RSA assumption it says that
strong RSA says that it's hard to take
any roots of a random element and
adaptive root says that it's hard to
take a random root of a given element
and
you can also so there's basically the
the kristef Peter Zack had basically a
protocol for the same problem which is
is it almost you can think of it as a
g'kar variant for exactly this this
problem the the only downside is that it
has logarithmic proof size and
logarithmic verification time so this
would get the total the overall proof
size to 2 lakh squared so it's a it's
certainly possible and we yeah it's just
for efficiency so now the whole protocol
it's you know we want to evaluate at a
point so in every round the prover sends
see LCR y0 and y1 does the proof of
exponentiation so we outsource that to
the prover and the verify checks
consistency between the Y's this can be
done efficiency efficiently right all of
these operations on the Y's are done mod
P and then we recurse so the problem is
that we already talked about this a
little bit that the size of the
coefficients grow in each route so what
we need to do is we need to say set Q to
be equal to actually it needs to be
basically check in the end that F is
less than P to the log D right it grows
in every round but this is just log D
times P bits so this is still F is still
small and it's important for the
protocol whether and I think I didn't
really say this at the end we need to of
course check in the final step we'll
check that as mod P is equal to Y that's
the final step
yeah so you can choose P completely
freely and it actually turns out what is
a no it probably will be I guess it only
depends on on P but it also only it's a
P only gives a lower bound to Q or
conversely if you choose a Q
it actually doesn't exactly bind you to
a specific P you could choose P after
you've chosen Q as long as P is small
enough so there's a that maybe wasn't
clear but let's let's focus on what we
have here and that can go into this
later so so in the final check I check
that the size of this thing is log D it
basically has a log D lambda bits and
but I need to set Q because in the
extraction the the bound on the
extractor polynomial it's also grows in
every round so basically I need to set Q
to be equal but now basically I need to
set Q to be greater than P to the to log
D so what is the security idea well it's
a it's a simple extraction argument
we're at the base round I get the
constant F directly and then in every
round I get two different transcripts so
alpha and and alpha prime for two
different to distinct challenges and
then I can just take a linear
combination from them and say that
computes CL equals to GE to the double
prime minus W divided by alpha minus
alpha Prime and this is an integer and
you might ask a why does this
necessarily have to be an integer what
if it's not an integer right what is the
W in W Prime's are such that this is not
an integer and the the answer is that we
just can assume that away we can break
some assumptions if this discrete
logarithm is not an integer and the nice
thing is these these assumptions are
falsifiable
so there
we the whole interactive protocol or
just relies on falsifiable assumptions
and and then of course we use Fiat Amir
to compile it to something on detective
the order assumption is actually implied
by the adaptive routing sumption so we
really only have two assumptions which
is the adaptive routing sumption and the
strong RSA assumption good what and if
we want a non-interactive protocol Fiat
to me with make run protocol so some
issues with that but people have you
know there's a lot of work now going on
to say so under which country we really
use it as a heuristic yeah I'm also
almost done
so how do we I said you know this whole
thing was was transparent right there
was no trusted setup so how do we
construct and the setup just consisted
of constructing this this group of
unknown order so a classical group of an
order that people use is an RSA group
but the problem is that has a trusted
set up right it has a one time constant
size trusted set up but it has a trusted
set up where I need to generate
composite the product of two large fans
well we can also use this other group of
unknown order which is a class group
which has been proposed to use for
cryptography a long long time ago
actually and the nice thing about this
class group is that it is you can
publicly sample them so it's just
defined by some large random prime the
group size is fairly large it's like
twelve hundred bits and we believe that
taking the the the computing the group
order and and taking all prime routes is
hard but there's a problem here actually
which is that it yeah odd prime routes
are hard right for the strong RSA
assumption what about square roots it
that there's actually as simple this guy
named Gauss came up with an algorithm
for for taking square roots and I can
you know usually I picked the prime such
that the I'm guaranteed that the order
of the class group is odd so I can take
power of two roots of any any element so
what this means is really that that if I
use these class groups I don't have a
commitment to integers what I do have is
a commitment to dyadic rationals which
are rationals
where the fraction is whether
denominator is a power of two it turns
out however that I can basically also
get a very similar encoding of
polynomials to dyadic rationals and then
the same techniques and tricks apply so
we need to be very careful with this and
and and we are in the paper and but it's
it's really important to to sort of
watch for these these powers of two
because the adversary can take powers of
two and commit today at aggression notes
but again we basically force them to
commit to bounded dyadic rationals so
we're both the numerator and the
denominator are bounded and I'll talk
about some optimizations actually
consider I have like three more minutes
so the proof size in every round I said
I sent see LCR y0 y1 well it turns out
that I actually don't need to do that I
don't need to send UCL and and y0 y l
because this can just be the the verify
as XS to see and from C and C are it can
compute CL and from Y and y 1 it can
compute y 0 so in total this brings down
the the proof size is one additional
element being sent in the proof of
exponentiation and at the end I open
this final F which is also log n times
log D times a times log B bits a lock D
lambda bits so in the end the size of
the one evaluation proof is has good
constants so it's to log the group
elements and to lock the field elements
and can do a further evaluate
optimization so say I want to evaluate
this not at a single point but at a
bunch of points or vector points then
basically the protocol just works almost
identically so I still only need to send
you two group elements I don't need to
send you now suddenly if I want to
evaluate the same polynomial endpoints I
don't need to send you to n group
elements I need to send you sort of n
Moorefield elements here in every round
but I don't need to send you more and
more group elements and it is important
because the group elements are much much
larger right they're sort of about maybe
ten times larger than the field elements
so it's too log D group elements and 1
plus n log D field elements nice
optimization is one that is often used
in these polynomial commitments when yes
homomorphic properties which is that if
I want to evaluate two polynomials at
the same point I can just basically take
a random linear combination between the
commitments of the polynomials and then
evaluate that random linear combination
and this doesn't cost me anything extra
there and in general what this means I
can I can evaluate if I have n
polynomials that are one evaluate at K
evaluation points the proof size really
only grows in K and it also only grows
in K with the with it with this very
small constant so well I guess log D
depend on a D but it's you know it's
only one additional field element per
additional evaluation point so in
supersonic if we use plunk which we'll
hear about later which is the set of and
which is an improvement on on Sonic then
we'll get proof sizes of I guess 8.4
kilobytes for four million gates and the
verification time is the total is a
guesstimate I think I use like ten
microseconds per group operation but if
you count sort of count up the number of
group operation it's same
five milliseconds for these million
gates that so it's a no I mean the the
one thing that is so a these groups of
unknown order are inefficient the second
thing which is annoying is that the F of
Q is actually D log D bits because Q
needs to be Q is basically log D bits so
F of Q is not just you ideally it
wouldn't have it be like D times lambda
bits but it's actually D log D lambda
bits so you lose a lock factor there and
you can regain that using pre-processing
so if you if you compute powers of
compute G to the Q to the I for all i
from 1 to D then you can be regain that
log factor but sort of that takes more
pre-processing so it's yeah it's not so
quadratic but it's quasi linear and and
and and really you know it's we often
drop the you know lambda terms which
probably we shouldn't because it's a
quasi so naively if you don't have
pre-processing then it's a quasi linear
number of group operations so but if we
have pre-processing then we can get that
down again to a linear number of group
operations and
so it's a it's basically logarithmic and
the number of coefficients so if it's an
N variate polynomial with degree D and
each variable then it's n times log D
right in and where it's polynomial has
multilinear it's gonna be number of
variables right so yeah but right yeah
any more questions
[Applause]